my talk of the table i really really
feel very very passionate about this
story it's about a fallen hero who
reminds us there really are good people
out there who like him are willing to
make the greatest sacrifice to help a
perfect stranger listen to this
17-year-old aiden perry will be laid to
rest today in sunrise florida he saw a
driver crash into a canal and he jumped
into the water to try to save them but
both of them died in a message aiden's
family wrote thank you for living your
life as a role model your final selfless
act is an example for others to follow
that driver aiden tried to save was also
a teenager and i like this the family
has started a gofundme page because they
want to raise money to help other people
not for not even for aiden i know about
this story i was talking to my sister
lynn and lynn's friend friends with
aiden's mother sarah perry and the
details are they're out walking the dog
he and his mom they see a
car go into the canal and they hear a
driver say help help help aiden
immediately took off his shoes tied up
the dog and jumped in the water and to
his mother's dismay he never came back
up again and it's revealed he's an
excellent swimmer but when he jumped he
didn't clear a ledge
he jumped in and broke his neck
immediately and the more i heard about
the story and i thought well did aiden
know this person lenny goes no didn't
know him he just knew that somebody
needed help and now sarah perry you know
thinking of her today has lost her only
child and it it it got to me because it
said to me that here is a kid
who went to help somebody else who we
didn't know that it a reminder that
there are so many good people out there
who want to help others at as we said
great sacrifice so i'm thinking of the
perry family today what a hero what a
hero to do something like that and it
says a lot about his parents yes where
do those values come from yes they come
from exactly right
it's a big price to pay